nobody was held responsible that's the  thing that that kills me Joe Biden goes  well I'm going to take responsibility  for if I make a mistake and then uh with  with Afghanistan or you're going to take  responsibility well there was weeks ago  it was just four or five weeks ago come  on man people falling from that didn't  happen the borders secure we're all the  it's very low right now like every  nothing nothing is his fault like like  with the gas prices he you know he's  like I I released all this stuff from  the Strategic uh oil petroleum Reserve I  did it I lowered those gas prices and  then they're calling back up and he's  like you gas stations you need to you  need to lower your prices I'm stuck I'm  price gouging I'm beyond thinking any of  this is a coincidence what but with  Afghanistan nobody nobody was held  responsible for for that for that drone  strike for for for everything the the  the terrible pull out